Buenas tardes.Good afternoon great Princeton
Class of 2018! Congratulations, huh?
Thank you so much for having me here.
Thank you President Eisgruber, trustees, faculty, parents, family
members, and friends.As I walked in I remembered
36 years ago when I entered this Chapel for
the first time.Then-President Bill Bowen
and many mentors, especially Arcadio Diaz
Quiñones, welcomed us, so I want to thank
them first, because they did what I call a
remarkable job welcoming in a young group
of students in 1982.
I am a member of the great Class of 1986,
and the second member of my class to speak
at Baccalaureate.Both of us are featured
on page 62 of our yearbook, the Nassau Herald,
just one next to the other.
We were both members of Quad Club
and we were friends.He was really into
computers. … At our 10th reunion, after many,
many beers, he was talking about using the
emerging internet to sell books, and we all
thought he was nuts! Well you all know what
happened. … He is now the wealthiest man in
the world and I am not.
[LAUGHTER]
So, I believe Jeff Bezos’ Amazon is doing
quite well. So, my first advice to you is
always attend Reunions. Always have as many
beers as you did last night, but invest early
in your classmates’ crazy ideas!
I am here to talk to you about public service.
But a different type of public service.
So, where should I start?Well,
I pledge my honor that I have not violated
the Honor Code during the
preparation of these remarks!
I know, I know. I know the whole controversy
this year. I’m not going to go into that.
Since the late 19thcentury those words have
been an integral part of Princeton. Allow
me to put them in context.Archivist April
Armstrong has documented that cheating … cheating
ran rampant at Princeton at the time.
Students saw it as a way to outwit the faculty, while
professors spent a great deal of energy trying
to catch cheaters.But something really
big happened: Student dissatisfaction with
that conduct of dishonesty and “sly warfare”
peaked in 1893.Back then, the most influential
seniors said enough is enough, and they themselves
proposed an honor pledge, and I quote, “to
elevate the standard of college morality.”
What do I love about that story?
Our Honor Code was not imposed on students.The
the leadership, the courage, the vision came from the
senior class.And they succeeded.Here
we are, 125 years later still embracing those
words.It is a three-step process:
First, a personal commitment to integrity,
and high standards of behavior.
Second, a commitment to hold others accountable
to a high standard of integrity.
And third, it’s a story about having the
courage to act.
You are about to depart Princeton. Believe
me, believe me … in the polarized political
and social environment of 2018, those words
are more important than ever.They represent
a commitment, a promise, and a responsibility
to confront an old and dangerous disease that
has destroyed many institutions and many nations
in the past, a disease that is making its
return with a vengeance: the culture of institutional
lies; what is now called “alternative facts.”
I decided many years ago that public service
was the vehicle to help right what I believe
is so wrong in America and in Puerto Rico.
Allow me to share with you my own roller coaster
life in politics, law and public service over
the past 30 years going back and forth between
different worlds; from the beautiful island
of Puerto Rico, to the complexities of Washington
D.C.; from many states of the union,
to countries in Latin America.
I am the son of Carmen,a “wise Latina”
born and raised in Puerto Rico. My mother
attended college in Massachusetts in the 1950s
at a time of profound racism in America.
I am also the son of Mohinder, an Indian man,
a Punjabi Sikh from Mirpur, in northern India.
His parents, siblings, and entire village were
massacred in 1947 by Muslim troops during
the cruel partition war between emerging Pakistan
and India.But despite their painful experiences,
and far from the hostility, hate, and resentment
that they could have very well borne, I grew
up in a home full of love, tolerance, and inclusion.
My parents taught me to speak up for those
who don’t have a voice and to loveal prójimo,
love thy neighbor.
Before I was born, my mother and father briefly
lived in Washington, D.C.On August 28,
1963, they joined thousands on the Washington
Mall to listen to a young African American
by the name of Martin Luther King.That
passionate “I have a dream” speech is
one of the most forceful, persuasive, and inspiring
acts of defiance of a young generation trying
to instill honor and integrity in this country’s
history. A simple, yet compelling principle:
what matters … what matters is the content
of our character, not the color of our skin.
It frightens me that more than 50 years later,
the opposite notion seems to be resurging
in today’s United States.
I was born in El Salvador in May 1964 — so
even Woody Woos can do the math in here; it
takes one to know one — exactly nine months
after Dr. King’s speech.Apparently, my
parents took to the next level Dr. King’s
admonition that “this is no time to engage
in the luxury of cooling off.”
[LAUGHTER]
My parents had moved then to El Salvador to
work at the U.S. Embassy in a project to fight
poverty in Central America, as part of President
Kennedy’s Alliance for Progress. So, I am
a proud Puerto Rican, conceived in El Salvador,
sorry in Washington, D.C., born in El Salvador,
with an Indian father, a Puerto Rican mother
and married to a wonderful woman from Panama.
Imagine how much fun I have
filling out the census form!
After Princeton, as President Eisgruber was saying, I spent a year in Chile.
It was 1986, and General Pinochet. His cruel
and repressive dictatorship, based on deceit,
lying about the principles of democracy and
a well-orchestrated state system to manipulate
public facts was in full force. I worked part
time with the Vicaría de la Solidaridad,
a Catholic Church effort to record human rights
violations. I also participated for a year
on an effort to collect pamphlets and underground
materials, a project conceived here in Princeton
by Professor Stanley Stein, his wife Barbara
and led then by bibliographer Peter Johnson.
In what is called today the Ephemera Collection right next door
in Firestone Library, Princeton is the only
institution in the world to have documented
and preserved decades of struggles of people
whose lives were being shattered.
The consequences of a government based on
dishonesty in Chile were devastating: people
were desperately trying to decry human rights
violations; people were afraid to be visible,
but absolutely needing to denounce the atrocities
being committed.
The greatest lesson I took from Chile is the
humanitarian cost that nations and people
pay when the lack of democratic consensus
leads to dangerous authoritarian governments.
Fast forward 32 years.An emerging and troublesome
climate of democracy and distrust seems to
be brewing right here in the United States.
It is a very simple concept: You cannot have
a democratic form of government if citizens
distrust each other and if dishonesty is a
form of life.
Believe me, what is happening is not good.
Political discourse is losing contact with
reality.When we let public speech be dominated
by discrimination, factionalism, fanaticism,
authoritarianism, demonizing the other, cult
of personality, religious intolerance … the
consequences are nefarious.As my father
learned firsthand in India; as so many of
our ancestors painfully learned, whether in
Weimar’s Germany, Mao’s China or Pinochet’s
Chile.
I don’t know about you, but I am starting
to hear too much of the same poisonous rhetoric
that lead in the past to heinous consequences.
This public discourse, based on so much information
that is simply not true, makes me question
whether governmentofthe people,bythe
people, andforthe people may actually perish
if we don’t do something about it.
I see it every day in my work in government.
Puerto Rico filed for bankruptcy in 2017,
and has been in an economic depression for
the past 12 years stemming from decades of
deceit and dishonesty by Wall Street and multiple
irresponsible fiscal and tax policy decisions
by both the government of the island and the
federal government in Washington,D.C.
We are now seeing the enormous consequences
of bond rating fabrications, ignoring experts’
warnings, and simply looking the other way
when serious, verifiable data was available.
Our citizens are now paying the price.Draconian
austerity measures are being imposed as we
speak, by the local government and an undemocratic
oversight board imposed by Congress.Hundreds
of thousands have left the island.
The lesson is loud and clear: Lack of integrity
has serious consequences.
And then disaster struck. On September 20th,
2017, we were devastated by Maria, the most
powerful hurricane to make landfall over the
island in over 100 years. We did not have
energy or running water for months; there
are some families still waiting.Up in the
mountains, children died of leptospirosis
after drinking contaminated water.The bureaucratic
response by federal and state authorities
was has been not only shameful but reprehensible
and immoral.Many people were left to survive
on their own.And mind you: Puerto Ricans
have been United States citizens for over
100 years. Some of us were frustrated and looking for
ways to help.Without any knowledge of water
filtration or plumbing, we bought over one
hundred 500-gallon cisterns and thousands
of portable water filters, borrowed a few
trucks, and spent three months installing them
in churches, community centers, and close to
water springs.With our makeshift system,
we were able to produce over 350,000 bottles
of safe drinking water per day and save thousands
of people from potential life-threatening
stomach viruses. Let me thank one of your
classmates, Diego Negrón-Reichard, who put
together a fundraiser last semester to help
finance this effort.
¡GRACIAS DIEGO! Thank you very much, Diego.
The New York Times reported back in November
thatinstead of pledging support for a large-scale
emergency relief plan, President Trump declared
that Hurricane Maria was not a “real catastrophe”
and complained that the storm had, and I quote,
“thrown our budget a little out of whack.”
He announced in San Juan that the official
death toll from the hurricane, allegedly 16
at the time, was the true measure of the government’s
response. “We saved a lot of lives,” he
boasted, and then flew back home.It was
his way to scale back on emergency federal
help and minimize the magnitude of the crisis.
That wasafter tossing around paper towels
during his visit to the island.
To this day the official death toll by the
government of Puerto Rico is 64 deaths.
Then truth kicked in just this past week:
The New England Journal of Medicine published
a shocking report last Tuesday by Harvard’s
School of Public Health.It estimates that
4,645 people died after Hurricane Maria.
The newly released study was conducted without
the collaboration of Puerto Rico’s government,
which the researchers said refused to provide
data to them.A real catastrophe indeed
that stems from government inaction, lying
to the people, posturing, and being blind
to reality: all symptoms of “alternative
facts” and botched data by the governments
of Puerto Rico and the United States.
Again, lack of integrity has real life consequences.
So, what are we supposed to do?
In such an environment, we need to wake up
and confront the culture of lies. There is
no time to waste. The voices of reason,
of honor, integrity, and honesty need to be
heard.I know it is not easy.
I returned to work
in Puerto Rico convinced that state and local
governments are the real laboratories of democracy.
What I saw shocked me. Our public schools,
where all poor children attend, for example,
have one of the worst achievement performances
in the United States.There are not enough
books in the classrooms; thousands of teachers
and students skip school every day. And
no one said a thing!The government and
the elite simply looked the other way.I
have been pushing for radical reforms. To
me, perpetuating poverty on the children of
the Island is not an option.
On the other hand, I have taken on the task
to condemn the culture at the electric utility,
the most inefficient, financially bankrupt
and expensive energy generation and distribution
monopoly.Electricity is vital for progress
in the 21st century. Just think how much sun
we have on the island! And yet, 98% of our
generation comes from burning fossil fuels;
less than 1% is solar.We are hostages of
an oil cartel of sorts. And yet, for decades
the political leadership and the government
of the island knew it but tolerated and even
celebrated this culture of dishonesty and
deceit.In both cases,
by saying enough is enough
I have had to confront very angry interest
groups.From the left and the right; conservatives
and liberals.The world of false stories
and alternative facts is not confined to one
ideology.In this climate of
confusion, misinformation,
and lies, nothing is more powerful than the
inconvenient truth of real facts, the strength
of honor and the persistent sound of our voices.
But let me warn you: It can get very lonely
out there in the wild forest of righting wrongs,
and instilling honesty in public service.
So, graduating seniors,
how can you live up
to the standard of Princeton in the Nation’s Service?
My clear invitation is to fight the
alternative facts disease wherever you are,
wherever you go, before it is too late.
Like the Honor Code created by students 125
years ago, you need to follow three mantras:
First, democracy needs from you a commitment
to personal integrity.Verify the sources
of information, ask the hard questions, and
educate others to do so. You have had the
best education in the world, and your generation
has more access to technology and social media
than any other before you.That comes with
a responsibility to spread the truth.
Second, you need to be brave and hold everyone
else to your high standards.SPEAK UP PEOPLE,
SPEAK UP,  you have the tools to have a voice
more powerful than any other generation.
And finally, you need to act and act quickly.
As Woodrow Wilson once said, “Life does
not consist in thinking; it consists in acting.”
Look around America today.There are fighters
out there confronting the culture of lies
and alternative facts; telling the truth and
reporting violations of vital principles and
values, just like Martin Luther King and other
leaders of the civil rights movement did in
the 1960s. Choose your cause and make
your honest argument.
Today, I salute the Black Lives Matter movement.
I salute the women all over the United States
in the #MeToo movement.
I salute the students at Santa Fe High School
in Texas; the Sandy Hook Elementary School
in Connecticut; the Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School in Florida, and so many others
who have been victims not only of senseless
school shootings but of senseless gun legislation.
I salutePresident Eisgruber and Harvard
President Drew Faust who two weeks ago urged
Congress to stop absurd deportations and provide
legal status for people from El Salvador,
Haiti, Honduras, Nepal, Nicaragua, and Sudan.
I also salute the thousands of excellent Latino
students in our colleges and universities
fighting not to be deported, targets of the
culture of prejudice.
But allow me also to salute my people of Puerto
Rico.Against all odds, Puerto Ricans are
up, fighting, resilient with a sense of purpose
in finding opportunity amidst the crisis,
with their hearts filled with hope and a renewed
commitment to rebuild our island.
All these brave men and women are saying enough
is enough with this culture of hostility,
of confrontation and intimidation.And yes,
of lies.Put all of this together
and it feels like
1893 again.
But this time around, YOU are the senior class.
We urgently need you to foster a National
Honor Code to stop this “alternative facts”
disease that is weakening democracy.
My hope is that at the Baccalaureate ceremony
125 years from now - in the year 2143 -
they will celebrate the great Class of 2018 whose
members had the vision and the courage to
take the moral leadership to do what was right
for the world.
El silencio no es opcion.
Silence is not an option. Class of 2018, denounce
what needs to be denounced; fix what is broken;
right what is wrong; and do not allow anyone,
regardless of their agenda, to use false data
and pretenses to confuse citizens and weaken
democracy.Be the vital voices to restore
democratic principles.Don’t look elsewhere.
It is you: the great Class of 2018! Speak
up, seniors, speak up!¡Hablen, seniors,
hablen!
Show the world what having honor is about,
what an honor code is, and how it works.
You must become the generation to restore
honor in America and the world.
There is nothing more honorable than making
people have hope in democracy again.
You have the honor; go live it; go teach it;
go act on it.
Thank you very much. Muchas gracias.
[APPLAUSE]